hey there everybody I'm Walter burn a Z
AK and this is top 5 Marvel's newest
film Thor Ragnarok just hit theaters
this past weekend too heavy critical and
commercial acclaim so today we're
celebrating by counting down the very
best Marvel has to offer
back in July I counted down the worst
Marvel films it's safe to say that
especially in recent years there have
been many more good than bad movies when
it comes to adapting Marvel stories that
mainly has to do with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe hitting its stride
with Iron Man back in 2008 and creating
mostly positively received films year
after year since however Marvel Studios
isn't the only production company
producing Marvel movies with spider-man
over at Sony for so many years and x-men
still under the Fox banner we have been
given a few great films from them as
well but when we throw them altogether
and compare them to each other which
ones stand above the rest is it the
obviously successful MCU movies or do
any Fox and/or Sony efforts eclipse the
rest we're gonna find that out right now
these are the top 5 best Marvel movies
number 5 spider-man homecoming it took
me a while to admit this but in my
opinion this is the best spider-man
movie ever made
after his thrilling experience with the
Avengers Peter Parker returns to New
York and begins a new phase of his
crime-fighting career as spider-man with
his mentor Tony Stark keeping an eye on
him Peter wants to be more than just a
friendly neighborhood spider-man but it
remains to be seen if he can handle an
even heavier burden at such a young age
when he discovers a criminal call the
vulture is creating and stealing weapons
with stolen alien technology Peter
decides to try and take him down all on
his own just in case you haven't seen
this yet I will be going into some
spoilers one of the main reasons this
movie hit the mark so well is because of
Tom Hollands portrayal of Peter Parker
he more than knocks it out of the park
Hollan balances innocence heroism
self-doubt and spider-man's signature
sense of humor in his performance Wow an
Ouya voices
I heard you got a bridge I know what a
girls sound like he is the epitome of
the young spider-man and I'm very
excited to see how he grows into a more
mature one Michael Keaton is absolutely
phenomenal as Adrian Toomes aka the
vulture probably one of his best roles
as he steals every scene he's in the big
twist involving him caught me and a lot
of people off-guard I did not see it
coming maybe the best scene in the whole
movie takes place right after it Killa I
actually didn't go up I saw it off on
the ground pretty lucky too he was there
that day don't spare me Walter is also
very relatable
it seemed throughout the film but
there's a particular exchange he adds
with Peter that almost has you on his
side the rich and the powerful they do
whatever they want guys like us you and
me don't care about us we've build the
roads and we find all their wars and
everything they don't care about us we
have to pick up bathroom ways to eat
their table scraps homecoming is filled
to the brim with heart drama and humor
Peter's relationship with Iron Man
encapsulate all three at different
points if you died that's like that's on
me
I don't need that on my conscience yes
sir yes I'm sorry I'm sorry I understand
I just want I don't be like you and I
wanted you to be better thus far it's
the best spider-man movie out there not
saying it's perfect though I think the
ultimate spider-man movie no pun
intended
has yet to be released but this was an
amazing start and I can see it getting
even better from here
number four Captain America the Winter
Soldier the Captain America trilogy
really kicked into high gear with this
movie since the events of the first
Avengers film Steve Rogers has been
working on high-level missions for
shield soon everything at that secretive
organization is torn down leaving Rogers
on the run from forces he once trusted a
weapon is then released to take down
Captain America and it is by far the
toughest opponent he's ever faced and
not just from a physical perspective
the Winter Soldier has connections to
Steve that make him unlike any enemy cap
has fought yet a ton of people would
argue that this is the best Marvel movie
made to date and placing it at number
four was a very difficult choice small
spoiler warning for this one as well the
advertisements for this movie made no
bones about the fact that Bucky is the
Winter Soldier it was pretty common
knowledge so the big reveal in this film
isn't so much a reveal for the audience
it's more about seeing Kap react to the
situation I'm with you to the end of the
line pal you're my friend
[Music]
Gizem located the Nami his love for his
childhood friend becomes the heartbeat
of the film while themes of freedom
versus security filled the conversations
with real-world importance in this
political spy thriller you know I read
those SSR files Greatest Generation yes
did some nasty stuff yeah we compromised
sometimes in ways that made us not sleep
so well but we did it so that people
could be free this isn't freedom this is
fear caps past is brought up in another
way and a superb scene with his
long-lost loved Peggy Carter I couldn't
leave my best girl now it's you as me
dance in addition to a strong
performance from Chris Evans the
supporting players here all fit into the
story well I really liked the chemistry
between Evans and Scarlett Johansson's
Black Widow
Lillian lip piercing right yeah she's
cute yeah I'm not ready number three
Captain America Civil War
I know it's called Captain America but
we all know this is really an Avengers
film the heavy collateral damage
sustained in sokovia during the fight
with Ultron and Avengers to spark the
governments of the world into action
they are forcing sanctions on the
Avengers to be regulated and overseen by
the world's governing bodies Iron Man
and a few others support this plan while
Captain America and the rest of the team
do not agree with it soon the
disagreement turns in to an all-out war
between friends and allies also secrets
are revealed that threatened to tear the
Avengers apart at their very cold it's
pretty much unbelievable that this movie
worked with all the cogs turning within
it the fact that it's this good is
nothing short of miraculous they
advanced several key characters
introduced new ones and inject plot
points very important to the overall MCU
that were previously unknown in the
hands of anyone else this movie would
have been an overstuffed mess but under
the careful guidance of the Russo
brothers and Kevin Feige Civil War is a
triumph
and the ultimate superhero team-up movie
so far they did a really good job of
building up both cap and Iron Man's
moral middle grounds there are points
during the movie where you can see both
sides as legitimate arguments its
internment she's not a US citizen and
they don't grant visas to weapons of
mass destruction
I'm doing what has to be done to stave
off something worse you keep telling
yourself that in addition to the badass
Black Panther Tom Hollands spider-man
nearly steals the show in his MCU debut
look when you can do the things that I
can but you don't
and then the bad things happen they
happen because evil and of course the
entire airport scene is incredible
everyone had a moment to shine and it's
truly something special
[Music]
as emotions pick up the farther along we
go into this story cap and Iron Man turn
their arguments into full-on brawls and
it's satisfying action-packed and
heartbreaking all at the same time stay
down final warning
we do this all day let's keep the
countdown going number two guardians of
the galaxy for a long time Guardians one
was my pick for the best Marvel movie
only very recently did that change
originally from Earth Peter quill was
abducted as a young boy and forced to
become a space ravager now an adult
Peter finds himself in the middle of a
galactic war over an aura peace toll
called an infinity stone its massive
power attracts the likes of Ronan a
ruthless warrior who means to destroy an
entire planet with it Peter runs into
trouble and gets out of it with the
unlikely help of Rocket Raccoon Groot
Gomorrah and Drax the destroyed together
these improbable heroes form the
guardians of the galaxy and look to stop
Ronan from destroying their homes
despite it dropping to number two I
still feel the most connected on an
emotional level to this movie out of any
of the others listed here it's got
everything and does it nearly perfectly
humor style music drama heart emotions
action character all these elements and
more add up to one of Marvel's best and
a real surprise hip before this movie
came out not many people knew who the
guardians of the galaxy were an almost
obscure Marvel comic about a tree a
raccoon and their friends in space
turned into a massive smash now everyone
knows star-lord and his companions as
well as any other character in the
Marvel movies this was an underdog story
both on and off screen all the main
characters have their own reasons for
doing what they're doing with strong
backstories to play off of
I could tell we were in for something
unique in that first scene the beginning
of this film rips your heart out
thank you
because
[Music]
Peter's development culminating in the
climax still gets me emotional he has a
great story and it's one I loved
following we can't talk about guardians
without mentioning it's pinpoint humor
I've seen the movie upwards of five
times and still laugh out loud
and a lot of the jokes find a backlight
places look like a Jackson Pollock
painting you got issues quilt it's real
totally fake that is the most real
authentic hysterical laugh of my entire
life guardians of the galaxy will have
me hooked on a feeling for years to come
this is one of the toughest countdowns
I've ever had to do there are a lot of
great Marvel movies out there so stay
tuned at the end of the show to see
where you can find me going into more
detail about these honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Marvel movie is
Logan not gonna lie I was pretty shocked
to discover that I now consider this the
best Marvel movie after my recent
rewatched though it seemed like I had no
other choice in 2029 the man once known
as Wolverine is now a broken-down aged
shell of his former self
he cares for his mentor professor
Charles Xavier who suffers from a
degenerative brain disease Logan is out
of the business of helping others in
order to survive himself and take care
of Professor X when a mysterious young
girl named Laura who seems to mirror
some of Logan's abilities unexpectedly
enters the fragile world of these hiding
mutants he is forced on one more mission
to protect the girl from forces looking
to destroy her Hugh Jackman could not
have picked a better story to go out on
we all knew going into this that Logan
was his last time playing the character
it definitely helped give the movie an
extra existential emotional punch as
this was all happening for the last time
there's an intangible sense of finality
to everything playing out on-screen but
knowing all that only enhanced what was
already there which is a remarkable
unique achievement Logan is unlike any
other superhero movie that we've seen
many critics point to the themes and
story being similar to a Western of
yesteryear the film itself doesn't hide
this comparison it absolutely does feel
that way and it works to its benefit
while Hugh Jackman gives a career
performance of a character he played for
17 years he's at his best in this film
when sharing a scene with the equally
impressive Patrick Stewart as Professor
X it turned out this was also Stewart's
final performance as his famous Charles
Xavier character the same place you
should take a moment I feel Charles the
world
it's not the same as it was their
chemistry leaps off the screen but no
one shined in this movie like Daphne
Kane's Laura the snarl the attitude the
motion it's all there as Keane exhibits
and undeniably powerful screen presence
there are finally some reports of
forgetting your own movie which needs to
happen as soon as possible bad shit
happens to people I care about Sammy can
I'll be fine
I've seen this movie three times now
including once in the black and white
noir format every time I've seen it I am
100% drawn into every single scene it's
a tour de force from start to finish and
it is the best Marvel movie made to date
I got rights to this one one I have a
lawyer now too if you'd like to hear
more thoughts on the honorable mentions
I talked about earlier head on over to
my personal channel where I'll be
discussing and ranking them in my new
show that countdown continued I have a
lot more to say about those films that
didn't make the top 5 so check it out if
you have a chance I want to hear what
you guys think what is your favorite
Marvel movie leave a comment and let me
know to stay in touch like my Facebook
page facebook.com slash awesome Walter B
and follow along on Twitter they take
part in more polls about what may be
covered in the future come back next
week as we bring our own brand of
justice to a new top 5 have a marvelous
day
[Music]
you